[Musique]
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
cela se passait il ya très longtemps
dans un petit village des cévennes
proche du mont aigoual autour de
l'église et de son clocher carré se
pressaient comme un troupeau sous la
houlette du berger les quelques
chaumières de montagnole où les hommes
et les bêtes partageait pacifiquement
les fruits de la terre
un après midi d'avril
comme tout le monde était au champ qui
se ment ou sarr clan qui taille en laye
où les arbres fruitiers
soudain le sol par us dérobé sous les
pieds en même temps une longue plainte
déchira le sens on aurait dit que la
terre d'un coup si brou et à la façon
d'un cheveu c'était de grands frissons
des secousses à vous faire chanceler la
peur s'empare à des paysans dont
quelques uns cherchent à fuir mais pour
aller où
partout autour de la montagne dansait
les arbres entre choquer leurs branches
les haies se contorsionnaient comme des
couleuvres blessés et par dessus tout
cette plainte lance ce hurlement à la
mort qui recouvrait le village et les
chants une place à laquelle s'était mise
à répondre par leur bellemans les
moutons terroriser et par leurs
aboiements les chiens affoler le calme
revint aussi brusquement qu'il avait été
rompu comme kiss éveillerait d'un
cauchemar
chacun se frottant les yeux puissant a
redit à faire quelques pas datant du
pied avec crainte cette terre qui venait
de le trahir
colette une gamine de 12 ans osa à son
père la question qui brûlait les lèvres
de tous pourquoi la terre se fâchent
tels papa question à laquelle personne à
montagnole pas plus le curé que leur
bout de n'aurait su répondre non plus
d'ailleurs qu'à celles concernant
l'origine des mystérieux gémissements
il semble bien pourtant à quelques-uns
que les plaintes qui avaient accompagné
les secousses du sol parvenait du lac
dyan lac qui surplombait le village
parce que ses rives était plus
verdoyante que la montagne alentours
julien le vieux patrac ils ont confié
les troupeaux de montagnole ils menaient
volontiers paître les brebis
ce jour là fabrice le frère de colette
un adolescent de 15 ans se trouvait avec
julien non loin du lac
or quand la nature autour de chance là
ils entendirent montée des eaux
la plainte déchirante qui en un instant
avait déferlé sur montagnole et la
vallée ainsi tout partait du lac dyan
depuis des siècles ce lac ne faisait
plus parler de lui si bien que les
villageois l'avait un peu oublié
[Musique]
pressé de questions par fabrice le vieux
berger qui savait beaucoup plus de
choses que le curé le rebouteux rappela
les temps anciens où le lac était
peuplée de génie une chronique remontant
à charlemagne et dont julien avait pris
connaissance dans le monastère où enfant
il avait appris à lire racontait qu
autrefois le village de montagnole avait
disparu sous les eaux obéissant aux
ordres des génies en colère le lac avait
bondi hors de ses rives et s'étaient
rués sur les pentes de la montagne
jusqu'au village qui avait été engloutie
fabrice terrorisé n'en croyait pas ses
oreilles montagnole submergées par les
eaux du lac
c'était trop affreux le garçon ne
voulait pas en croire ses oreilles ne
voulaient pas croire une telle chose
possible
je peux t'en apporter la preuve lui dit
alors julien suis moi
confiant le troupeau au chien le vieil
homme et l'enfant traversait un petit
bois de chênes verts et longeant le
versant qui dominait le village à tenir
une terrasse caillouteuse ou ne poussait
qu'une herbe rase et sèche à côté d'un
rocher grille julien montera à fabrice
un morceau de ferraille dans lequel on
pouvait reconnaître un soc de charrue
tu vois ce soc lit le berger il est tout
couvert de rouille
mais si tu regarde avec plus d'attention
tu découvriras autre chose
l'adolescence accroupi sur le métal
rouillé
ces petites bosses blanchâtre et
cannelés qu'il effleura du doit
ressembler à des coquillages
ce sont des coquillages en effet
confirmé le berger le soft que tu vois
ici à ces journées assez longtemps sous
l'eau pour que ces coquillages s'y
accroche
voilà la preuve qu'à une certaine époque
toute la vallée a été recouverte par le
lac et les génies question à fabrice
julien haussa les épaules
personne ne les a encore vu et personne
ne souhaite les voir le soir de ce même
jour ce n'était plus tout à fait vrai
les génies s'étaient manifestés et à
jules précisément il les avait vus alors
qu'il s'apprêtait à ramener les brebis
fabrice était déjà redescendue au
village
le soleil se couchait derrière la forêt
tout d'un coup
sans le moindre souffle de vent la
surface du lac s'est amusé à
millionnaire cela ne ressemble pas à les
vagues on aurait plutôt dit que
d'énormes bulles d'air crever les eaux
et dans ces bulles le parc figée de
stupeur vie grimaces et d'affreux visage
c'était des crânes bosselé luisant sans
le moindre cheveu avec des fronts la
bourrée de profondes rides les oreilles
s'écartait des tempes en forme de
navettes dont la pointe se dressait en
l'air de sorte que le vieux berger les
avait d'abord prises pour des cornes à
la place des yeux il y avait deux trous
éclairé d'une lumière phosphorescente
lemay partagé en deux la face
horizontalement chacune des marines
s'élargissant presque jusqu'aux oreilles
la bouche enfin offrait deux l'ip
repoussante violette agitaient de
grimaces et découvrant des dents dont
chacune était un petit poignard mais le
plus effrayant était le nombre et
l'agitation de ses apparitions
on aurait pu en compter des centaines
des milliers cela grouillait
littéralement ceux des ordinands au ras
de l'eau parfois s'enfonçant pour
ressurgir tout de suite après avec des
ricanements diabolique lé crâne lisse
recueillait les derniers rayons du
soleil et dans les orbites des lueurs
verte clignotaient le spectacle
s'interrompit tout d'un coup sûr un
grand cri comme red bull il fonde la ddt
les offres de vars et al julien ce quoi
rappela les chiens est pris avec le
troupeau le chemin du village à la
veillée il réunit chez les parents de
colette et de fabrice les habitants de
montagnole auquel il rapporte à ce qu'il
venait de voir le rebouteux n'avaient
pas d'opinion
on alla chercher le curé qui décréta
qu'il y avait du diable là dessous il
fut décidé en conséquence d'organiser
dès le lendemain une procession à
l'oratoire de saint michel archange
vénéré comme celui qui lors de la
révolte des anges terrasse à lucifer la
cérémonie a eu lieu en présence de tous
les habitants de montagnole soit
quatorze adultes et deux enfants fabrice
et colette
selon son habitude celle ci avait sonné
la cloche pour appeler les paroissiens
manière brand est en tête avec le curé
en chape de soie rouge
la procession se dirigeant en priant
vers l'oratoire située à mi chemin entre
le village et le lac les hommes et les
femmes chantaient en toi qui au fond des
abîmes envoya le cruel dragon et cartes
de nous tous péri et saint michel nous
en supplions pas revenue devant la
petite chapelle qui abritait la statue
de l'archange et dont la porte était
ouverte à deux battants les fidèles sa
genouillères des cierges allumés par
colette faisait scintiller le casque le
bouclier et la lance de saint michel au
moment
le curé s'apprêtait à réciter une raison
en latin la terre se mit à trembler il y
eut des cris de terreur
ce qui n'avait pas été précipité au sol
vire soudain la statue chanceler sur son
socle puisse abattre à grand fracas sur
les balles le casque en tombant rebondi
l'as lens se brisa net et dans un bruit
ce sinistre le grand bouclier à la
frapper un vitrail qui vola en éclats le
sol fut encore ajouter deux trois ou
quatre secousses puis ce fut le calme
plusieurs se trouvait à terre parmi les
débris du sein
beaucoup vire dans l'événement un
avertissement redoutable la guerre
n'était elle pas désormais déclarée
entre le village et les génies si
ceux-ci ne respectait pas l'archange
saint michel
qu'est-ce qui pourrait endiguer leur
menace pendant une semaine les habitants
de montagnole vécurent dans la pire
inquiétudes
chaque soir on guettait le retour du
berger pour savoir si les génies ne
s'était pas à nouveau manifester ont
commencé à reprendre espoir
lorsqu'un matin un grondement emplit
l'air ce qui était déjà au chant
tournaire instinctivement la tête du
côté du lac ce qu'ils aperçu alors les
remplit des pouvoirs août
une immense vague de rouler dans le ciel
balayant tout autour
les arbres entiers étaient déracinées
desrochers énorme arrachés et emportés
dans le tourbillon l'eau en rugissant
s'engouffrait dans la vallée menaçant
héberger les jardins les prêts les
maisons isolées
mais le plus surprenant était que cette
vague tournait sur elle-même et parfois
s'arrêter comme si elle hésitait sur la
direction apprend on la vit même un
moment rebrousser chemin par quelle
magie une si grande masse d'eau des
fillettes est là si les lois de la
pesanteur
pendant ce temps au bord du lac où il
avait dès l'aube à mener les troupeaux
julien était le témoin d'une scène
encore plus effrayante à l'endroit où
était né et doux avait jailli dans un
grondement la monstrueuse vague un magma
grouillant était apparu soudain le pâtre
reconnu tout de suite les affreux génie
ce n'était plus seulement leurs
horribles tête qu'il avait cette fois ci
sous les yeux
c'était aussi leur corps frénétiques ces
monstres n'avait pas deux bras et deux
jambes mais une dizaine de tentacules
qui lançait à droite à gauche avec
lesquels il s'est très niais les uns les
autres
ses membres en forme de serpent était
d'un viol est sombre
contrastant avec la pâleur du visage et
du tronc réduit à une boule flasque
couleurs de cire
combien y avait-il de génie dans ce trou
au milieu du lac qu un sortilège
empêcher les eaux de combler julien eût
été bien en peine pour faire le décompte
dans ses formes démoniaque s'entassaient
et s'en mêlait dans le plus grand
désordre
lorsque leur tête émerger de la masse
mollet visqueuse
il semblait au vieux berger que leurs
yeux le foudroyait de leur flamme verte
que leur boucherie y est sarcastiquement
il était quant à lui incapable de bouger
si les génies s'était précipité sur lui
il n'aurait pas pu faire un geste tant
de leader le paralyse
il retrouve l usage de ses jambes
quand l'énorme vague revint bruyamment
s'enfoncer dans le lac plus de génie
plus de sifflements ni de grondements
julien rejoignait ses moutons les
comptes à l'ére compta il en manquait
deux après ce qui s'était passé on
aurait pu s'attendre à pire
la base sur les pentes de la vallée les
habitants de montagnole recommencer à
respirer après la terreur que la vague
avait fait naître en eux et eux aussi
firent l'inventaire des dégâts
un bosquet ravagé deux barriques de vin
emporté un âmes noyées et quelques
chants transformé en bourbier
lorsqu'on su que julien était sauf
on se dit que cette fois encore on
l'avait échappé belle mais la prochaine
fois
pour parer à toute éventualité il fut
décidé de tenir prêtes en permanence
trois barques dans lesquels ont mis
quelques provisions
en outre il convenait de surveillé jour
et nuit les abords du lac
je viens se chargea tout naturellement
de cette mission en alternance avec le
père de fabrice à la moindre alerte
celui qui se trouvait près du lac
soufflerait dans sa corne sur les pentes
surplombant montagnole il serait relayée
par le sifflet de l'un ou de l'autre des
villageois enfin dans le village même il
était prévu que colette qui en avait la
charge pour les messes dominicales
sonnerait la cloche le surlendemain la
corne retenti en fin de matinée fabrice
se trouvait un peu ou dessous du lac en
observation il siffla aussitôt en
redescendant vers le village
derrière lui un grondement terrible
couvrit le son de la corne les eaux se
précipitaient sur le versant ce n'était
plus ce coup-ci une seule vague mais un
torrent bouillonnant et boudy sans
fabrice couru plus vite sans cesser de
siffler le vacarme des eaux
empêcherait-il qu'on entendit du village
son sifflet ils aperçus en train de
détacher son âme pour le mener auprès le
rebouteux l'adolescent siffla encore
mais ils s'époumonait talonné par les
eaux musy sentent il accéléra sa course
si bien que à bout de souffle et ayant
heurté une pierre il tomba avant que le
feu ne le recouvrir il eu le temps
d'entendre la cloche
fermât alors mes yeux à la fois
terrorisée par ce qui allait se passer
est satisfait du devoir accompli
avertie par lui colette sonel à la dans
l'église à 7h désertent la fillette
tiraient sur la corde le coeur battant
dès qu'elle avait entendu le sifflet de
son frère elle avait couru à son poste
en levant la tête elle apercevait se
découpant sur le bleu du ciel
la grosse cloche qui frappait le marteau
il n'était pas nécessaire de sonner
longtemps pour que tous s'entendent
colette se préparait donc à rejoindre sa
mère lorsqu un fracas assourdissant lac
loi sur place l'eau se ruaient dans
l'église après avoir fait sauter hors de
ses gonds le lourd portail il était trop
tard pour fuir la fillette ne savait pas
nager l'aurait-elle sud ailleurs que la
brutalité avec laquelle le flou se
ruaient contre les murs et les piliers
ne lui aurait pas permis de survivre
affolée colette sauta sur un banc lolë
recouvrit aussitôt et l'entraîna dans un
tourbillon alors luttant désespérément
contre le courant la fillette se hâta
vers la corde du clocher elle s'y
accrochent à des mains et des mollets et
ben dans tous ses muscles elle celle va
peu à peu au dessus de l'eau qu'elle
entendait bouillonner soudaine elle
parvint ainsi les mains en sang
jusqu'aux battant de la cloche sur
lequel elle sa seat à califourchon
sauver
peut-être si l'os est saine
colette se pencha vers la masse liquide
ce qu'elle vit lui arracha un cri
d'horreur et lui fit perdre connaissance
dans le village comme prévu les
habitants avaient regagné les barques
celle-ci ne furent pas longue à être
soulevées par le torrent et tous
découvrir alors le spectacle qui avait
horrifié colette dans les flots descendu
du lac méforme hideuse se
contorsionnaient mêler aux cadavres des
moutons aux débris de meubles à toutes
les épaves qui tourbillonnaient dans les
remous les monstrueux génie dans cesse
poursuivait agité leurs tentacules et
lançait de temps en temps ce
gémissements épouvantable qu'on avait
entendu le premier jour lorsque la terre
s'était soudain dérobé sous les pieds
des villageois dans les barques les
femmes hurlaient de terreur
tandis que les hommes à grand renfort de
ram tentait de fuir ces lieux sinistre
mais les génies était partout le
cauchemar durera jusqu'au crépuscule
les eaux commençaient à ce moment-là à
décroître
les génisses et en retirer on gagne à un
promontoire qui avait échappé à
l'inondation
c'est alors que les parents de colette
et de fabrice qui espérait que ceux ci
étaient montés à bord d'une autre barque
que la leur dur se rendre à l'évidence
les deux enfants avaient disparu
la mort dans l'âme le père repris la
barque et les rames
il retrouva fabrice assez vite par
miracle l'adolescent avait réussi à
prendre place dans un tonneau qui
flottait sous la lune
le père et les fils naviguer ensemble
jusqu'aux abords du clocher dont la
partie supérieure seul émergeait cole
est revenue à elle se balançaient avec
le bat en faisant retentir la cloche de
cousseau
il ne fut pas trop périlleux de la
récupérer par l'auvent à l'exception de
julien emporté tout de suite après qu'il
eut donné l alerte
tous les habitants du village englouti
était donc sauf les génies se
satisferaient t-il d'une seule victime
peut-être à montagnole réoccuper après
le retrait des eaux ont pris l'habitude
de donner en exemple aux générations
futures le courage du vieux berger et
s'est ainsi bien que les génies du lac
ne soit plus jamais manifesté que la
mémoire des jours de terreur s'est
conservé jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]